hello I'm the Nostalgia good guy
remember it so you don't have to you
know I start to think about all the
Christmas specials that don't get that
much attention and I start to think
about the ones that probably deserve not
to get that much attention but still
have a few scenes that should be looked
at anyway and then I started to think
about Texas Roadhouse no particular
reason I was just hungry and then I
realized wherever than do like a top 11
list or just choose one special to talk
about I decide I'm going to talk about
the specials that deserve more attention
and even better talk about the specials
that maybe our great beginning to end
but still deserve to be look at for one
or two really great scenes because so
much can be done with Christmas that
even if the special isn't popular or
even that good there can still be great
wonderful stuff that's still worth
mentioning the only condition is I'm
gonna try and not talk about the ones
that I already discussed in my two best
Christmas specials lists because well I
talked about them already
and you can go check out those videos
for themselves this is just a look at
some Christmas specials and Christmas
scenes that probably deserve more
attention than they get but that's it
let's take a look at one of my favorite
Christmas specials that always warms the
heart with its kindness and humble
nature I'm of course talking about
RiffTrax insincere kisses to you all in
2009 retract in the vent riffing
Christmas shorts in front of a live
audience
they even got Weird Al Yankovic in on it
aside from the comments being hilarious
hell it is RiffTrax the overall
atmosphere is 100% Christmas from the
sweaters they wear to the shorts they
watch and of course the hilarious
commentary before dances with
this was the most dignified portrait of
Native Americans RiffTrax is usually
funny enough on their own but to have a
live audience listen and laugh along
with you just makes the experience all
the more enjoyable and that adorable
girl grew up to be a beautiful woman
named Orlando Bloom there's even the
scene where the audience laughed so hard
that they dropped three jokes because of
how long it dragged out I need you
tonight
worth every moment if you feel bad for
missing it don't worry it's still
available on DVD and streaming it's
definitely the perfect combination of
joy and cynicism short pops cynicism is
often a big factor in a lot of Adult
Swim shows and nowhere is it more
prominent than Aqua Teen Hunger Force is
that the plague of snakes they asked for
oh yeah this isn't as much a Christmas
special from beginning to end but one
that accidentally becomes a Christmas
special simply through bad events
meatwad gets a magic t-shirt that can
grant him whatever he wants
he was just for the Easter Bunny Easter
Bunny's twin brother Daryl and then
finally Santa after accidentally burning
his flesh off don't ask it out of
nowhere ends with our trio trying to
save Christmas this is so funny because
it's not built up as a Christmas special
it just kind of happens out of nowhere
in a strange way that makes it one of
the funniest setups ever one that didn't
even know at the beginning it was going
to be Christmas related the fact that
it's so out of the blue just makes it
all the more hilarious it's okay it's
okay Santa just take your time okay
something similar can be said also about
bad Santa are you saying there's some
role in my gear I'm sorry you're here
Willy my fuckstick now obviously this is
going to have something to do with
Christmas but the film itself is so mean
so depressing and so not carrying
traditional Christmas messages that it's
hard not to be intrigued by how
miserable it is for kids beat me up one
time I went crying home to my daddy you
know what he did he made it a little
better now he kicked my ass the lengths
it'll go in it's mean spirited nature is
the focus of where all the comedy comes
from it gets so mean-spirited that even
when the main character does something
that's still horribly bad but for a good
reason
we accept it as some sort of Christmas
miracle still if you're up for the
height of unconventional bad Santa's
definitely want to check out you know
why cuz you enter the bathroom among
these dishes what the fuck for every
insanely depressing Christmas special
there's always going to be an insanely
positive Christmas special and that's
where pee-wee Herman comes in his
Christmas special is another one of
those that isn't groundbreaking or doing
anything that new he'll if anything it
borrows and satirizes from a lot of
other traditional specials but it does
it in such a crazy a bizarre way it's
hard not to enjoy it it's like peewee is
putting all these things in his special
because he hears this is what you're
supposed to put in specials the majority
of celebrity appearances are almost
completely pointless and yet there's
just so many that keep popping up all
over the place hi share buy share hi
Magic Johnson bye Magic Johnson how
strange is that
it's so bizarre but at the same time
it's so Christmas look at all the detail
of these sets they're obviously fake but
they're just so colorful and hammering
in the holiday atmosphere when I think
an abundance of Christmas this is the
first special that pops into my thanks
secretive yeah if you're into
over-the-top stuff like me this is
definitely a classic to look at but hell
with the positive stuff you want to see
the mean-spirited shit again how about a
giant robotic Santa killing people
Futurama definitely has a creative take
on the future and one of the funniest is
how Christmas is actually a time to keep
indoors and stay with your family not
because of love and goodwill but because
there's a psychotic robot Santa who
kills anyone that's outside on Christmas
night or sorry they pronounce it Xmas
night I'm going to shove coal so far up
your stocking you'll be coughing up
diamonds it's just funny to see a joyful
holiday being spent running for your
lives away from a blood hungry mental
case sharp teeth and gunfire what's not
to love it's definitely a fun psychotic
little romp to look at broke out birth
I'm dreaming of a red Xs but like I said
before there's good stuff to find in
specials that even aren't that good I'm
alone for example is a holiday classic
but home alone too even the people who
made it admit it was mostly a cash in on
the last movie but even with that
there's still some really great scenes
in it some of the acting is still funny
the shots of Christmas in New York are
nicely done and let's be honest Tim
Curry makes this movie cost keeping
beats up have a lovely day as far as I'm
concerned when his scenes are over you
can stop watching the film he just owns
every scene that he's in I think that
image of the Grinch transforming into a
smug smile is ingrained in everybody's
head now how can you not think of him
whenever you see that scene again
I love you hell I actually enjoy
watching the Alvin and the Chipmunks
Christmas special not for the story
which is cheesy but harmless but simply
for the backgrounds look at these these
are just so golden and warm I could
watch the special on Butte and still be
totally happy
not to mention animation legend Chuck
Jones did the character designs and
speaking of which did you know that
outside of the grinch chuck jones did
another christmas special well okay -
but what the fuck was that I'm talking
specifically about a very merry Chris
and drum of rehashing the same plot
despite all that it still ends on a very
strong and uplifting finale
again maybe too similar to the first one
but the artwork in the tie-in to
christmas still makes it totally worth
the search i can look at the drawing
style in both of these endings all day
they're just so nicely done another city
based comic i'm surprised isn't getting
more attention around Christmas is Tokyo
Godfather's directed by another late
animation legend Satoshi Kon three
homeless people a transgender woman a
runaway teenager in and out of work
alcoholic try to confront their past
that have been haunting them while also
trying to figure out the location of a
baby's parents who was left in a
dumpster
it's a weird setup to say the least and
I'm sure a lot of people are thinking
it's another three-minute a baby
scenario but it's actually a very dark
very surreal yep still surprisingly
uplifting film that's totally crazy but
so embraces the crazy it's one of those
films that never goes quite to corny but
also never goes quite to me neither
it's the perfect balance of dark reality
mixed with hopeful enlightenment very
similar to a Christmas carol in that way
in fact that's another one deserves more
attention okay okay maybe not Christmas
Carol in general but the first one I
ever saw which strangely enough starting
Mickey Mouse yeah that's right Mickey
friggin Mouse you think this be doomed
to be some sort of plan commercial
tie-in but especially for its short
running time it's a damn impressive
telling of the Dickens classic I mean
come on
Scrooge McDuck has Ebenezer Scrooge how
much more fitting can you get any
jackanapes who thinks else should be
boiled in his own pudding but it isn't
just squeezing Disney characters into
famous roles it actually captures the
essence of the story in a short amount
of time and as you legitimately care
about what's going on the sad scenes
though quick are really really sad have
you ever seen Mickey Mouse cry before
it's pretty fucked up trust me when I
say it might be short but they take
advantage of every moment they got just
like the Disney spirit should finally
I'm gonna discuss a new Christmas
classic that I may have discussed before
but nevertheless everyone deserves just
yes it's Arthur Christmas
wantyou is amazing I've already done a
whole editorial rounded so if you want
more details you can always check that
out but for a quick sum up it has some
of the most fastly paced and inventive
comedy ever associated with the Santa
mythos but not only is it funny as hell
and throws a ton of jokes at you but it
also has the same wonderful spirit and
character story and its visual style
that any great Christmas classic should
have I've gone on and on about it before
but if you haven't seen it yet
definitely do yourself a favor and check
it out this year so even if the
Christmas special isn't fantastic from
beginning to end it's still worth
checking out for some of its moments
because they're just such great moments
and I'm sure these aren't it for the
unknown Christmas classics that need
more attention so much material is made
year after year that I'm sure I've
overlooked a time go ahead and leave in
the comments below which christmas
specials you think got overlooked which
moments you think are some of the best
and keep drawing attention to those
heartwarming classics that make us
appreciate this heartwarming holiday
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember
because it's fine
you